and now to a tragic story in the north
valley where a high school student has
died
it happened at legacy high school and a
letter from the school principal
indicates
it happened as an athletic practice was
starting sasha loftus joining us now
live tonight from legacy with the latest
details
sasha
denise school officials tell us that
student died here at legacy high school
after suffering
a medical emergency earlier this week
the school's principal sent a message to
parents tuesday informing them of this
tragic incident
the message indicated this happened
before an athletic practice at the
school on monday
the letter also asked parents to reach
out to grief counselors if their
children need support
ccsd also released a statement saying in
part quote
ccsd is deeply saddened by the sudden
passing of one of our students
the district is in mourning over the
loss of this young life
our thoughts are with the family and
loved ones of the student during this
time
it is never easy to lose a valuable life
especially
at a young age of course we are still
learning more
about this situation this is still a
developing story stay with us
as we get more both on air and online
but again ccsd and legacy high school
are
encouraging any parents their students
may have known this particular student
to reach out who are struggling with
this news
to their crisis team their crisis
response team for now reporting live
tonight sasha loftis
8 news now